[Music]
i'd like is proud to know that seth a
very good man he took a red-eye flight
to be with us uh on this program
well how was the flight uh the flight
was good it was fine which is good
because i very recently i i had i had a
very bad flight recently um
that it was much better then and uh it
was uh i i recently i often i had a very
early flight a few months ago and i was
very hungover uh because i drink a lot
sometimes
and in order to deal with the hangover i
thought it'd be a good idea earlier in
the morning to eat a brownie i had that
had some herbal components that
i probably was this was probably a bad
idea honestly i'm gonna say it was not a
good idea combined with what i did next
which was i got to the airport and i was
hungry because i was hungover and i had
eaten this brownie and uh and the only
thing in my terminal was a burger king
and i uh it's like seven in the morning
and i look and what they have new on the
menu was something called an angry
whopper
uh
i don't know the angry whopper i know
the whopper but what's the angry one
it's like a whopper but with like
jalapenos on it and like pepper jack
cheese and like chipotle some barbed
wire exactly barbed wire
[Laughter]
and so uh i ordered the angry whopper
and even the guy behind the counter was
like really like you're gonna get that i
was like give me the angry guy working
at burger king i don't know if i'm
against it
he put on a mask
he put it on the plate it burnt through
the tray yeah and uh i ate the angry
whopper i downed it fast um and then i i
got on the plane and i i instantly fell
asleep and now when i i when i'm
hungover and once i've eaten an angry
whopper i sweat like a maniac like it's
crazy right and so
i was sleeping on the plane i assume
sweating like crazy probably having a
vivid dream
and i'm suddenly woken up by a flight
attendant shaking me and she goes sir
you've just had a seizure
[Laughter]
i think
oh my god did i just have a seizure and
then she literally screams is there a
doctor on the plane
to which a guy responds yes i'm a doctor
and he starts running over to me and
it's all happening so fast but i have
the thought in my head at this moment
it's like i didn't have a seizure i ate
an angry whopper this morning man
and so
the doctor's checking me out and i'm
embarrassed i'm just like i don't know
if i don't think i had a seizure i
really don't think i did and he's like i
don't know we should check you out you
should drink a lot of water i'm like
okay the doctor leaves and the woman's
there's a woman sitting beside me and
i'm like did i have a seizure and she's
like i don't think you had a seizure sir
i was like well talk up you're my person
here and so
i kind of forget about it honestly i'm
making playlists on my computer for the
rest of the flight we land and as soon
as we land the flight attendant comes up
to me again and she goes just we've
landed i want you to relax the
paramedics are here waiting for you
like i don't need that but i didn't want
to cause a scene and so they literally
come on the plane and we're like where's
the guy and i'm like i'm the guy and i'm
like i'll just walk out with them and
then we'll end it out there
no joke we get out of the plane another
paramedic come up to me and said the
ambulance is at the curb waiting
we can go we can go with
i was like this is gonna get bad very
fast they put a thing on my finger they
was like beep beep beep but i'm oh no
and so at that moment i literally i
pulled the thing off my finger and i
said everyone relax i did not have a
seizure i had a marijuana brownie and an
angry whopper
[Applause]